hey there everybody welcome to Tokyo
greetings from Tokyo in the world
premiere of Detective be be serious Ryan
you know I made it work wins we're here
I think we've done everything but pinky
swear on the fact that we're actual
friends so how about the fact that we
are actually here you are actually here
because of your daughter change she's
the one that made this happen pretty
much yeah she's kind of the arbiter of
everything I do
really yeah I get permission slips did
she get the check because she liked the
voice she liked how you sounded as
Pikachu does she get the check for that
she does I think how about this tonight
though this is such an amazing ground
basic turnout this is I've never seen
anything like this this is wild I mean
Tokyo is an amazing city just in and of
itself but the fact that this many
people came out I don't know how many
thousands of people here it's great it's
cool if you were a Pokemon what would
your superpower be my superpower be I
don't know man I like I like I mean I
gotta say having the power of
electricity the electric was pretty
sweet so I don't know of anything top
stat does a recent detective pikachu's
on the poster you know we talked about
how the jet lag was just debilitating
it's amazing have you woken up and just
oh I missed the family and dialed them
and it was actually like 3:00 a.m. I
mean I'm surprised I haven't woken up
hanging upside down got a bath
or like I've woken up just like in the
middle of an interview while I was here
it's kind of amazing jet lag is brutal I
think they have all the floor scientists
doing all day why can't they cure this
that's a good question
I've been disco napping like a mug all
week I know I know me too I was
literally fell asleep in the car and I'm
like on my way to this crazy event I
shouldn't be able to fall asleep like
that so now you told me that you were
actually gonna take the kids to see this
movie on opening day you guys gotta go
to the theater you're gonna make it a
family event or you
Theater yeah I mean there's nothing
beats a theater experience that's pretty
amazing so to be an extra community like
that it's fun
[Applause]
[Music]